SPEAKER: Hey everybody.
Thank you so much for coming
to Google Detroit today.
We are super excited to have Mt.
Joy, a folk rock based
band from Los Angeles.
They just started
their fall tour
and just actually
earlier this year
released their first studio
album called "Silver Linings."
We are thrilled
to have them here.
They have just kicked
off their fall tour
which goes from now
through about Thanksgiving.
Just four shows in, I think.
They spent the weekend in
Wisconsin and St. Louis.
After tonight when
they play The Shelter,
they're going to be headed out
to New York, I think, next.
But you guys are absolutely in
for such a huge treat today.
These guys are amazing.
And we are happy to welcome
Michael, Sam, Matt, Sotiris,
and Jackie to the stage.
They're going to play a
couple of songs for us.
So let's give them a big
Google Detroit welcome.
Woohoo.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT QUINN: Hello everybody.
How's it going?
You guys have
delicious food here.
If all else fails,
you've still got that.
All right.
This one's called "Sheep."
[MUSIC - MT. JOY, "SHEEP"]
[APPLAUSE]
MATT QUINN: Thank you.
Thank you.
OK.
Sorry.
I can't get off my mind
Jackie's from Portland, Oregon
and she said this is
her favorite weather.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I guess we can
introduce ourselves.
That's Jackie on the keys.
JACKIE MICLAU: Hi.
MATT QUINN: Sotiris on the drum.
Usually there's more than one.
Michael on the bass
and Sam on the guitar.
SAM COOPER: This is Matt here.
That's him.
MATT QUINN: Hey.
And I dropped off
an application,
so if you want to look
that over let me know.
This one's called
"Silver Lining."
Thanks so much again for
having us and listening.
And we appreciate it.
We're Mt.
Joy.
I think this is going to work.
[MUSIC - MT.
JOY, "SILVER LINING"]
[APPLAUSE]
MATT QUINN: Thank you.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: OK, everybody.
Thank you so much.
And how about one more huge
round of applause for Mt.
Joy.
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
MATT QUINN: All right.
SPEAKER: Just want to
do one more quick round
of introductions.
So from my side
over, this is Sam.
Hey, guys.
This is Michael.
This is Matt.
This is Sotiris
and that's Jackie.
JACKIE MICLAU: Hi.
SPEAKER: So all right, you guys.
I think the first
thing I'd love to do
is just learn a little
bit more about the band,
because from what I read,
you guys are relatively new.
You've been together
a couple of years.
But I cannot believe the amount
of touring you did in 2017 from
Electric Forest to
Bonnaroo, all over.
And you just released
your first studio album.
So first question.
Where does the name Mt.
Joy come from?
SAM COOPER: So Matt and I--
Matt's in the middle here--
we met in high school
outside of Philadelphia.
And Mt.
Joy is just a little
mountain between our houses
where we first
started making music.
SPEAKER: Is it true--
I think, speaking of, did I hear
that you used to record songs
in your brother's room, Sam?
Is that right?
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
My brother had like a
little crappy console thing.
This was in like--
you were in ninth grade maybe.
MATT QUINN: Yeah.
SAM COOPER: I'm two years older.
But yeah.
I think we were in high school.
And we would make some
dumb songs and things
in my brother's room.
But--
MATT QUINN: They were not dumb.
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Did any of them
make it onto the new album?
SAM COOPER: Did any of the--
SPEAKER: Any of
those crappy songs?
SAM COOPER: No.
Weren't they-- I forget
what they were about.
MATT QUINN: The original
was about we caught--
I don't if they have these here,
but those stink bug things.
When I was in that age,
for whatever reason,
they attacked America.
It's one of the most vicious
attacks on our homeland.
And they were truly everywhere.
And so we started--
me and my friend
captured them and
would keep them to see
how long they would live.
I have no idea why.
This on the internet.
Oh my God.
So yeah.
Then we wrote a song about
one because it lived forever.
SPEAKER: Stink bug, huh?
MATT QUINN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: So that's
how you guys met.
And then if I'm not
mistaken, then you randomly
ran into each other in Los
Angeles not that long ago.
SAM COOPER: Kind of.
So Matt and I had some
songs we wanted to record.
And for whatever reason, we were
just like, we need a bassist.
So we went on Craigslist
and we found Michael.
SPEAKER: That's what was
going to be my next question.
Craigslist.
MICHAEL BYRNES: Yeah.
In the man seeking group of men.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: That's
where you posted?
SAM COOPER: That's
where we found him.
SPEAKER: And you auditioned
Michael obviously.
And was he your first
choice or how did that go?
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
No.
It was-- we literally--
we were talking about
this the other day.
We went to like a little room
in Studio City or something--
MICHAEL BYRNES: North Hollywood.
SAM COOPER: North Hollywood.
And we just started
playing these songs.
And then Michael was like,
oh, my roommate can record us.
And then Michael's
roommate Caleb from--
MICHAEL BYRNES: From Detroit.
[INAUDIBLE]
SAM COOPER: From Detroit.
SPEAKER: Woo.
SAM COOPER: He recorded
the first few songs.
SPEAKER: So Sotiris,
how did they find you?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: I
was friends with Michael.
We were doing a gig together.
And then I think a few
months after we met,
maybe like a year--
less than a year after
we met, he hit me up.
And here I am now, nervously
answering a question.
SPEAKER: You did great.
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Last but not
least, Jackie, I'm
pretty fascinated with you.
I first of all watched some
of your Instagram stories.
And I've seen you playing
piano and keyboard
at random places like in
the airports and whatnot.
So tell us first.
We heard that you're
from Portland,
but tell us how you
joined the band.
JACKIE MICLAU: Yeah.
So I moved to LA two years ago.
And I actually met everyone
through Michael's friend.
So yeah.
That's how that happened.
SPEAKER: And I know you're
only a couple performances
into the tour, but how
is it being the only girl
on the road with these guys?
JACKIE MICLAU: Oh, it's great.
SPEAKER: Any secrets to
share of how you manage that?
JACKIE MICLAU: I'm the princess.
No, I'm just kidding.
No, everyone's super chill.
I think we've got this
family vibe going on.
So yeah.
It's cool.
I have like four brothers now.
SPEAKER: Four brothers
and best friends.
That's great.
JACKIE MICLAU: BFFs.
SPEAKER: Let's talk about
the album a little bit.
So "Silver Lining."
Amazing album.
Cannot believe you
guys posted one--
I don't know if it was
a song off of the album,
but you, on a whim, just
posted a song up on Spotify
and were blown away
by how many plays
you got in the first 48 hours.
Is that song on this album?
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
So that was actually recorded
at Michael's apartment.
It's called "Astrovan" was
the first song we put out
almost two years ago now.
But then we rerecorded
some of those songs.
But that original "Astrovan"
was the original one
from Michael's house.
But the album wasn't even
a thought at that point.
It was just let's put
some songs online.
SPEAKER: Who owned
the Astro van?
You're in the Motor City, so we
got to talk about cars somehow
I guess.
MATT QUINN: Yep.
I don't know.
I don't know where I
got that reference.
A lot of the songs
at that time were
sort of these sense of
humor joke kind of things
because we weren't facing
the public in any way.
It was just trying to
make lighthearted songs.
It was really more like I was
picturing the character Jesus,
not necessarily in
a spiritual way,
but like him being
this carpenter
guy that was like a stoner.
Trying to put him in 2018,
like what that would look like.
And that's just the
car I felt like he
was going to be driving around.
I don't know.
SPEAKER: So back to the album,
the inspiration for it I read
varies from '60s and '70s rock
all the way through current.
It's interesting
because the first time
I listened to it I felt a
huge My Morning Jacket vibe.
And I actually did feel a
little bit of a Deadhead
vibe come through.
So hopefully I'm a
little bit on with that
if you want to talk about
the inspiration of how
you came to put this
compilation together.
MATT QUINN: Yeah.
I mean that's--
I think, at least Sam and I grew
up on a lot of '60s, '70s music
just from our parents.
And it has always stayed my
favorite music, which I know
doesn't happen for everyone.
So I learned to write listening
to Grateful Dead, Bob Dylan,
Paul Simon, all of that stuff.
And then there's more
contemporary bands,
My Morning Jacket's
definitely an inspiration.
So that's cool.
And I don't know.
I think, again, the beginning
of and writing of the songs
was really pretty--
there wasn't ever a thought
of, all right, let's try
to make something that
sounds like My Morning Jacket
or anything like that.
I think that stuff
came out naturally.
I don't know.
SPEAKER: Well, where does
your inspiration come
from personally when
you sit down to write
or when you sit down to play?
Do you have a guilty
pleasure, some kind of a venue
that you like to create
in or get creative?
And actually, I'd love
to hear from each of you
if you don't mind
answering this question.
Whoever wants to start.
MICHAEL BYRNES: Want
to just go down?
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
I mean I think our
songs, for the most part,
start just on acoustic guitars
and then build from there.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: So actually,
Sam, that's a good point.
So if you start--
as a guitarist, if you
start on acoustic guitar,
how would you bring someone
like Jackie in on the keyboard
into an inspiration?
SAM COOPER: I don't know.
I think we just start playing.
Like we have a bunch of
ideas now that we've just
been working with for album
two, whenever that ever happens.
But I think it's just
finding these threads
and working on them.
It's hard because
we're on tour so much.
There's not a ton of time
to work on these things.
But finding that
time and just trying
to tie the threads together.
SPEAKER: What
about you, Michael?
Where does your
inspiration come from?
MICHAEL BYRNES: As far as bass
playing, especially in Mt.
Joy, I think it's
very just reactionary.
I lack a certain skill
in just sitting in a room
and putting a song together
by myself for whatever reason.
And so I think for
me it's usually
when there's like a skeleton
of something occurring, that's
where I sit in best is
hearing something and reacting
to it on the bass, whether
it's just one note or a bunch
of notes or whatever.
That's where I draw
my inspiration from.
MATT QUINN: I don't know.
I think in terms of where I like
to create, I think a lot of it,
at least on this record,
was like that thing
where you can't fall
asleep or there's
some sort of odd
energy in you where
you're restless in some way.
And I think, for me, that's the
best time to pick up a guitar
or start being creative and
just trying to channel whatever
that energy is that's like
stopping me from doing what
I want to do into like song or
whatever that ends up being.
SPEAKER: Like an
ex, or some kind
of fight, or some
restless night?
MATT QUINN: I don't know.
I think it's just insomnia,
or weed, or whatever that is.
Instead of scrolling
through my phone
until like the end of time,
I just pick up a guitar.
And I also scroll through my
phone through the end of time
as well.
SPEAKER: Are you scrolling
through social media?
We're at Google so we have to
have some digital questions.
MATT QUINN: Yes.
I do this thing where
it's like a loop,
especially if I've been
smoking or something where it's
like I'm back at Twitter
somehow even though I've
gone through
everything on my phone,
I open it again even I know
everything that's in there.
And that's what I
know I'm like, oh no.
SPEAKER: I think we just
cracked your insomnia issue.
Social media.
What about you, Sotiris?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS:
I'd say, yes.
If anyone has like a
skeleton of a song,
I like to work
around that or just
sit in a room with just the
drums and just mess around
and see what happens and
then maybe show these guys.
Yeah.
That's about it.
And if weed's
there, weed's there.
If it's not, it's not there.
SPEAKER: Uh, Jackie,
last but not least--
MATT QUINN: There goes
that Google application.
[LAUGHTER]
JACKIE MICLAU: When
I create, I think
it's kind of like what
kind of a day I'm having.
If I'm feeling a
certain way, I kind of
write based on those feelings.
But for this project,
I think a lot of it
is just, like, vibing.
And we've been
touring together for,
like, what, like, a year,
a little over a year now.
And so it's just kind of
figuring out where we all
fit in, and coming together
with different ideas,
trying new things
out every night.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: So I was
looking at all the places
that you have yet to go.
I know you're four
cities or so in.
How do you pick
a tour like that?
Do you feel like as the
musicians of the band,
that you have any
say in where you go,
and landing in
Europe, for example?
Why don't you answer that, Sam?
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
We have an agent who
maps things out for us.
But we definitely have a say.
Like, we get to go to
Europe later this year,
which is going to be crazy.
But we've been touring--
I mean, I know this tour just
started, like, four days ago
or whatever it is,
but we've really
been touring pretty
nonstop since early March.
And so we're kind of
starting to hit cities twice.
And from there, you kind
of just have to expand.
And I guess Europe's
going to be awesome.
SPEAKER: I read that NPR
said that you guys are
a great festival band.
How do you feel about
playing festivals
versus being on tour together
and playing at places
like the Shelter tonight?
MICHAEL BYRNES: A lot of
free stuff at festivals.
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
MICHAEL BYRNES: A
lot of open bars.
There's a lot of--
sometimes free shirts and shoes.
So it's pretty sweet.
SAM COOPER: Festivals are great.
There's always a ton of people.
But there's something
about your own show
where you know
that people aren't
just kind of like
wandering over a field
because they hear music.
They bought a ticket,
and they're into it,
and they're watching and
listening and appreciating.
SPEAKER: Bonnaroo,
Lollapalooza, Electric Forest.
There's not much
you haven't done.
But is there a festival
that you are kind of
hoping to get an invite to?
And we are recording
this, and this will go up
on the YouTube channel.
MATT QUINN: Looks into camera.
SPEAKER: Looks into camera.
MATT QUINN: I don't know.
I think Coachella
would be awesome.
I'm probably,
like, missing them.
I don't know.
I'm not, like, a--
SAM COOPER: Sasquatch
would have been cool.
But--
MATT QUINN: Yeah.
Oh, yeah, I--
SAM COOPER: --it's gone.
MATT QUINN: --always
wanted to do that.
And then they retired it
because we wanted to do it.
SAM COOPER: Yeah, exactly.
JACKIE MICLAU: Burning Man.
SAM COOPER: Burning Man.
Yeah.
MATT QUINN: Yeah.
SAM COOPER: No, we can't
afford to go to Burning Man.
SPEAKER: Just missed
that, just a week or so.
SAM COOPER: Next year, yeah.
SPEAKER: Sotiris, I know
you're terrified of me
throwing a hard ball at you.
So I'm going to ask what was
your favorite thing that you
had from the lunch
at Google today?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Well,
the mushroom risotto--
is that what that is?
SPEAKER: That was good.
SAM COOPER: Stroganoff.
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS:
Stroganoff, I'm sorry.
Yeah.
I love mushrooms and Italian.
[LAUGHTER]
SAM COOPER: The food?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS:
The food, yeah, yeah.
SAM COOPER: Not
the hallucinogen.
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS:
Everyone, it's OK.
Calm down.
MICHAEL BYRNES: We truly
don't do as many drugs
as it seems right now.
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: No, no, no.
I honestly-- I do love
mushrooms, like portobellos,
cremini, the whole--
SAM COOPER: We get off the
stage, and we drink LaCroix.
That's it.
We're not that band.
MATT QUINN: [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
SPEAKER: We're big
fans of LaCroix here.
So we'll hook you up afterwards.
Along with a Froyo machine, too.
SAM COOPER: Oh, my god.
OK.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
Please.
SPEAKER: OK.
So Jackie, Matt said that
you love this weather.
I wish it would have been
a nicer, sunnier day here.
There's all kinds of stuff
happening in Detroit today,
actually.
We've got the Lions playing.
We've got the Tigers playing.
And of course, we have Mt.
Joy playing at the
shelter tonight.
But can you talk a little
bit about your journey
from Portland to Los Angeles?
And you know, we have a
Women@ group here at Google.
And we like to talk a lot
about empowering other women.
So we'd love to
know if you've had
like a little secret to your
success so far on your journey
from Portland.
JACKIE MICLAU: Oh, man.
Yeah, well, I moved to LA
just kind of on a whim.
It was random and
so not like me.
I think I decided
in July of 2016.
And then I moved
out September 2016--
that same year.
But yeah, I think just
surrounding yourself with,
like, a good community
of people who
are going to encourage you to
pursue what you want to pursue.
And then just being
confident, knowing
that you put in the
work, and everything else
will come, as long as you
put yourself out there.
So--
SPEAKER: You went from
one of the rainiest cities
to one of the sunniest cities--
JACKIE MICLAU: I know!
SPEAKER: --in the country.
JACKIE MICLAU: But luckily,
we're touring so much.
So I'm not there, ever.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Um, do you guys all
have your cell phones on you?
SAM COOPER: Uh--
JACKIE MICLAU: Sure do.
SPEAKER: OK, cool.
All right.
We're going to
play a little game.
Pull those on out.
SAM COOPER: All right.
SPEAKER: So one of my best
friends from my childhood
is actually here today with me.
And before I have you
look on your phone,
we're going to
start with you, Sam.
We're going to do a little
lightning round of questions
to get to know
each of you better.
What would-- just
pick one word-- what
would your best
friend from childhood,
whether that's Matt or someone
else, use to describe you?
SAM COOPER: No.
I have to do this for myself?
SPEAKER: Yeah, you.
SAM COOPER: Ah.
JACKIE MICLAU: I'm
going to text mine.
SAM COOPER: Half Jewish.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I have no idea!
I-- yeah, let's go with that.
SPEAKER: That's your answer.
OK-- half Jewish.
SAM COOPER: Sure.
SPEAKER: Mike?
MICHAEL BYRNES: Oh, we're
going down the line.
This is tough.
I grew up in Oklahoma,
so probably just liberal.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I grew up with some
really conservative friends,
but they're still good friends.
SPEAKER: Sure, absolutely.
What about you, Matt?
MATT QUINN: Goofy.
SPEAKER: Goofy.
Sotiris?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS:
Extremely confident.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT QUINN: That's two words.
AUDIENCE: Hyphenate it.
SPEAKER: And Jackie?
JACKIE MICLAU: Introverted--
I'm actually sweating up here.
[LAUGHTER]
SAM COOPER: It's
so cold in here.
SPEAKER: OK.
So pull those phones out.
This is something we
actually make our clients do
when they come to Google.
Well, not-- we don't make them.
But it's usually, like, a fun
icebreaker, if you don't mind.
And maybe you might have to
censor this a little bit.
But take a look on your phone
and tell us the last thing
that you Googled.
SAM COOPER: So I don't
have my phone on me,
so I already failed.
But I know what it is.
SPEAKER: OK, yeah.
Tell us if you know.
SAM COOPER: It was in the back.
We were trying to figure out
the Little Caesars Arena.
We're trying figure out how
long it's been here in Detroit.
And--
SPEAKER: What'd you learn?
SAM COOPER: Well, I learned
that the Red Wings used
to play the Joe Louis arena.
And then the Pistons played
at the palace in Auburn Hills.
And now they're both
here, behind us.
SPEAKER: That Google, it's a--
SAM COOPER: Google's great.
[LAUGHTER]
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah, actually,
when you walk back out,
notice that the original, before
there was a Joe Lewis arena,
was Olympia--
was the name of it.
It was The Olympia Barn.
The original sign from that
stadium is actually right here.
You can see it from our windows
here on the fourth floor,
the big Olympia logo.
It's pretty cool.
There's more stories.
I don't know if
Dave Hoffman's here.
I'm sure he's happy
to share, if he is.
[? SAM COOPER: ?]
That's pretty good.
SPEAKER: What
about you, Michael?
What's the last
thing you Googled?
MICHAEL BYRNES: Aw,
it's going to make
me look like I do more drugs.
But I was Googling articles
about Elon Musk's blow
back from smoking a
blunt with Joe Rogan.
SPEAKER: Hilarious.
Wait, was there a blow back?
I just saw the interview.
MICHAEL BYRNES: A little bit--
I was just reading an article
about how the Air Force doesn't
know how to handle it.
I guess they're, like, people
are requesting them to start
an investigation on Elon Musk.
SPEAKER: It's legal.
It's legal where he
was when he smoked it.
SAM COOPER: That's true.
SPEAKER: It's legal.
MATT QUINN: So I'll
lead the investigation.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: OK, Matt, what
did you actually Google?
MATT QUINN: This is actually
crazy for where we are right
now.
But me and Sotiris were
trying to figure out
how many users certain social
media applications have.
So I Googled--
I just have the
list of the number
of users on the top
social media applications.
SPEAKER: And what is that?
What's the top?
MATT QUINN: So
Facebook's number one.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MATT QUINN: YouTube
is number two.
And then WhatsApp, followed
by Facebook Messenger,
which is a loser move.
That should be-- whatever.
[? MICHAEL BYRNES: ?] It's
two things [INAUDIBLE]..
MATT QUINN: They
can't have both.
MICHAEL BYRNES: Yeah.
MATT QUINN: And then
WeChat and then Instagram
and then some foreign ones.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
I was doing some
research on you guys.
You guys have 4,000
subscribers on YouTube.
It's very good.
That puts you into a
top creator profile.
You have about 7,500
fans on Facebook.
You have about 3,000
Twitter followers.
And on Instagram,
you're killing it.
You have 13,000
followers on Instagram.
But by far and away,
your YouTube music plays
and your Spotify plays
are just off the hook.
SAM COOPER: [? Is that right? ?]
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Your streaming music services
are getting a lot of use.
SAM COOPER: Cool.
SPEAKER: Keep it up.
Good work-- who is your--
before we get to you,
Sotiris and Jackie,
who is your social
media manager?
Is it amongst the five of
you, or do you outsource that?
SAM COOPER: I kind of run
the Instagram and Facebook
for the most part.
And our manager kind of
just fills in the rest.
But we all kind of have
access to the account
and put up stories and
goofy stuff along the way.
SPEAKER: Is there
anything off limits
that you don't put up there,
since you are a public persona?
SAM COOPER: There are
things that are off limits.
But--
SPEAKER: You can't
talk about them?
SAM COOPER: I mean,
like, I don't know.
Like, naked pictures?
I don't know.
SPEAKER: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: I feel
like that's assumed.
That's a given.
SAM COOPER: Well, you
asked the question.
I'm going to answer it.
No.
I don't know.
We all just kind of just--
I think we're all--
MATT QUINN: I didn't know
naked pictures were off limits.
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I'm going to delete Matt's
access to the accounts now.
MATT QUINN: Well,
I run the Twitter.
So that's fair game.
SAM COOPER: That's true.
Matt does run the Twitter--
MATT QUINN: I think Twitter--
you can have naked pictures.
MICHAEL BYRNES: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SAM COOPER: Come on.
What are you waiting for?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Doesn't sound very
brand safe to me, but Sotiris,
what's the last
thing you Googled?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS:
So mine was the thing
that Michael was talking about.
But I guess before that was
lyrics to a Cold War Kids song.
So shout out to Long
Beach, California.
SPEAKER: What-- were you
looking for the lyrics
because you're going to maybe
sing for us a little bit,
a cappella here,
and surprise us.
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS:
It was-- no, no, no.
No.
My phone just turned off.
It just died.
SPEAKER: Oh, weird.
[LAUGHS]
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Yeah.
I was just-- I was
trying to figure out
what song it was during a--
and I watched a live set
on YouTube.
And I was googling
the lyrics, because I
didn't know what song it was.
So now I do.
SPEAKER: Now you do.
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Ah, Jackie!
JACKIE MICLAU: Oh, boy.
I googled Mac Miller,
rest in peace.
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Aw.
SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
JACKIE MICLAU: Yeah.
Couldn't sleep last night.
SPEAKER: Well, Jackie.
Actually, let's start with
you with the second question.
So let's talk YouTube.
What is your favorite YouTube
channel or a content creator,
if you have one?
JACKIE MICLAU: Ooh.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: I mean,
if that's too hard,
what is, maybe, the last video
that you watched on YouTube?
JACKIE MICLAU:
Probably a Mac Miller--
SPEAKER: Yeah.
JACKIE MICLAU: --YouTube video.
Yeah.
But-- I'm sorry.
SPEAKER: No, no,
no, please, please.
JACKIE MICLAU: YouTube--
I watch a lot of,
like, music videos.
That is, like, my go to.
SPEAKER: What's your
favorite music video or music
genre to watch on YouTube?
JACKIE MICLAU: I'll watch
anything John Mayer I can find.
SPEAKER: Oh, he's your guy?
JACKIE MICLAU: He is my guy.
SPEAKER: Would you--
JACKIE MICLAU: If
you're watching--
[LAUGHTER]
JACKIE MICLAU: --I
can be your girl.
No, just kidding.
SPEAKER: Is he single?
I think so now.
JACKIE MICLAU: Based on
my YouTube search, yes.
SPEAKER: All right.
Well, if we have any John
Mayer connections out there,
let's hook her up.
Hook a girl up.
MICHAEL BYRNES: Can't
you just Google?
Like, I'll bet you can do that.
Yeah, just strong arm him.
SPEAKER: This gets posted
on the worldwide web.
Sotiris, what's your favorite
YouTube guilty pleasure
or creator or last video?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: I
watch a lot of drum stuff.
So there's a lot of drum
tuning videos and drum sets.
But I think a good comedy
one is Good Neighbor, which
is like the dude, Kyle Mooney,
from "SNL" and then his guys.
If you go watch that
stuff, it's very funny.
That's all I can think
of, top of my head.
SPEAKER: Do you find yourself
watching a lot of TV, too?
Or are you watching
more streaming services?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Yeah, more,
I guess, streaming stuff--
yeah, don't watch much TV.
I guess just "Seinfeld" is
the only TV I really watch.
SPEAKER: And you watch
that probably through Hulu
or YouTube or something--
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: --or Netflix?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS:
Yeah, exactly.
SPEAKER: What about you, Matt?
MATT QUINN: I don't know.
A lot of, like, music
stuff, for sure.
But also, kind of
sports are my get away
from all of this stuff.
So I watch a lot of
House of Highlights.
I watch a lot of this
guy Frankie Vision, that
does a lot of, like, basketball
highlights pretty quickly.
And yeah, no, that's probably--
SPEAKER: So what's your team?
Do you have a football
team, baseball team?
MATT QUINN: I'm
Philly all the way.
SPEAKER: Philly?
MATT QUINN: So I
grew up in Philly,
so all the Philly sports teams.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
Michael?
MICHAEL BYRNES: For me, I
watch a lot of gear reviews,
like, music gear reviews.
So there's one in particular
called pedals and effects
that's all about pedals and
effects over there behind you.
And it's run by
these two funny guys,
one bass player I really
admire and one guitar player I
really admire.
So-- and "Hot Ones"--
I watch a lot of "Hot Ones."
SAM COOPER: I watch
a lot of "Hot Ones."
MATT QUINN: Ah,
that's a good one.
SPEAKER: What's "Hot Ones?"
MICHAEL BYRNES:
Ooh, it's so good.
It's an interview
show in which this one
guy does the interview.
And he asks 10 questions.
And with each question
they eat-- both of them,
the person being interviewed
and the interviewee--
--er, interviewer-- they
eat a spicy chicken wing.
And they get--
with each question,
it gets way more spicy until
the last hot sauce is just,
like, diabolical.
SPEAKER: Oh, my god.
I totally could have
taken you in that today.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL BYRNES: I'll go.
I mean, I'm sure I'm not--
I'm not--
SAM COOPER: I can't do spicy.
SPEAKER: That's crazy.
MICHAEL BYRNES: But
it's very funny.
And the guys ask
really good questions.
And as the food gets spicier,
people don't have much--
they don't think about what
they should and shouldn't say.
They're just getting
the answer out.
So it's a good show.
SPEAKER: I'll have
to check that out.
MICHAEL BYRNES:
Yeah, it's great.
SPEAKER: And last,
but not least, Sam.
SAM COOPER: I watch
a lot of Tim and Eric
on YouTube, just because it's
very short, simple, stupid
videos that make you
stop thinking entirely.
[LAUGHTER]
But then we also--
we just put out
a music video for
our song "Bigfoot"
by our friend Steve Gerard.
And that is on YouTube as
of, like, four days ago
or something.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Can you tell us,
speaking of that video--
oh, my god, if you guys
haven't seen it, go watch it.
How did you make that
costume for "Bigfoot"?
I've seen it in my nightmares
a couple times now.
SAM COOPER: So
Steve did all of it.
Steve Gerard-- he
did all-- he actually
did our album cover, too.
But yeah, he does all of our
artwork, and he's a genius.
He's an insane genius.
SPEAKER: He's not here, is he?
SAM COOPER: No.
SPEAKER: I was going to say,
you are a weird guy, Steve.
[LAUGHTER]
That's very cool.
And did you have to shut down
Times Square to do that video?
SAM COOPER: I don't
know how he did it.
I think they went out at
like 3 AM with a guy dressed
as a bat-pig man on a bicycle.
And, like, drove in
front of him in a car.
You got to watch the video.
It's probably making no sense
right now if you've seen it.
SPEAKER: A very good video,
though, and a great song, too--
so well, I was going to ask
you about that album cover.
But you just did.
And that was going to
be my last question.
So we only have a
few minutes left.
Are there any questions
from the audience
that we could open it up to?
Anyone brave enough
to take their hand?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
We've all met, but Jason here.
Could you talk a little
bit more about [INAUDIBLE]??
Like, your band
t-shirts, your posters,
the inserts for the vinyl--
it's all got, like, a really
cool, unique look to it.
Was that all Steve?
SAM COOPER: Yeah, that's
literally all Steve.
So I met Steve--
I was studying abroad
in West Africa.
And I didn't know anybody.
And he was on my trip with me.
We became really close friends.
And he would travel everywhere
with a little journal.
And he would just draw these
dumb, goofy little things
everywhere in his
little journal.
And then, like, eight years
later, we started this band.
And we were, like, what
should the aesthetic be?
And I was just thinking,
like, oh, my god-- like,
there's Steve!
So he drew the bison, the
sheep drawing, the cardinal,
the album cover,
the music video.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Any other questions?
Well, one more
question, actually,
if there aren't any
from the audience.
Raise your hand if this is
your first time in Detroit.
Nope?
So you guys have all
been here on a tour,
I'm guessing, at
some point in time.
Is there any favorite
scenes you like
to check out when here, or
favorite bar or restaurant,
or even place to play?
MICHAEL BYRNES: I like this
bagel place in Corktown,
called the Detroit
Bagel Institute.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Yeah.
MICHAEL BYRNES:
It's pretty banging.
SPEAKER: What's your order?
What's your bagel?
MICHAEL BYRNES: A lox,
you know, that's the move.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I like Detroit a lot.
It's really cool.
It's like there's a lot of
hidden things in Detroit.
Everyone looks at it
and thinks it's just
a desolate, like,
apocalypse town.
But--
MATT QUINN: I don't think
everyone looks at it
and thinks that.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Well, there was a time.
It's coming back now.
MICHAEL BYRNES: Yeah.
But I really like this place.
SPEAKER: We're happy
to have you here.
Any other favorite
Detroit haunts?
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Google.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Obviously.
SAM COOPER: The Joe Louis
Arena and the Palace and Little
Caesars.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: The other two are
gone now, so here you are.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, then, LCA is now
your favorite place.
So it was such a pleasure
to have you guys here.
Not only are you such an
incredibly talented group
of musicians, but you're an
absolute joy to be around
and to get to know.
So if you find yourselves
ever back in the Motor City,
will you please come again?
Maybe on that slip
about album 2--
[LAUGHTER]
SAM COOPER: Yeah.
SPEAKER: --if
that's in the works.
SAM COOPER: We'll be back, yeah.
SPEAKER: We would
love to have you guys.
Thank you so much for
coming to Google Detroit.
Let's get one huge round
applause again for these guys.
[CHEERS, APPLAUSE]
SOTIRIS ELIOPOULUS: Thank you.